today's topic got a little video from
you guys
featuring kevin samuels what about those
of us that require diversity
i found marriage and one woman to be
incredibly boring
i might remarry when and older but am
only 32.
there you go you're 32. what's gonna
happen when you 50
how much do you need man i'll tell you
what
you'll get old real quick 34 is probably
already getting pretty damn old
because it sounds like you've never had
a loving relationship with a woman
you've never had a woman rub your head
and tell you it's gonna be all right
and never had a woman you see guys
who've never had a woman's love you're
missing a lot
even though even the crazy stuff they
want to see in these spaces
fbi women beautiful women who are
feminine and inspirational
provide a hell of a lot more than just
what let's just
how much do you need the way he said it
there's light kills
how much [ __ ] do you need
yeah i get it we've had this
conversation yes we did right
we talked about this in private and all
this stuff and this is like after a
while it's like
how much more diversity do you know i
mean
no no i did live this came from our live
stream and so i wanted to ask him about
this because
off time to manosphere this is like a
very talked about topic
and i talk about discipline when it
comes to even the bedroom stuff
because i know what it's like to spiral
out and to engage a lot of it so
the net of it was
men who have not had a quote unquote
sexual feel think that life is going to
just be a non-stop
acquisition of new women
and it's not i mean there comes there's
a relationship between a man and a woman
that we're only that that supersedes
the bedroom and i think that's the
problem we don't
value what each of us brings to uh
outside of that this is why you look at
people when they map up when we look
over at celebrities
um if if having all these multiple
millions and billions
this meant you could have concubines or
whatever why don't they have them
because most people don't want that
and i would say this number two number
one number one number two men who are
really
on their purpose you're busy all the
time
yup i'm busy all the time
we the first time we physically spoke
was in this live stream because we are
so
dadgum busy what listen real [ __ ]
we're so busy we're busy
making money that's what it really comes
down to i think um
i think people have this misconception
i've heard people say this to me a few
times too they're like
yeah man now that you like made it must
be like so easy must be out there and
i'm like it's completely the opposite
now that i do this work full time and
i'm on this like bro i've had
faith when's the last time you got out
where's the last time you got out forget
this when's the last time you just i'm
not talking about
open the door not open the door get your
uber eats just
how to walk outside just a little around
the corner bro it's been a minute
it's been a minute it's been a minute
let's not even talk about girl
let's talk about you leaving this got
darn place
man i got work to do it's got money to
make god damn
you know and um i would probably say the
last two years since like things have
really started to like pick up
i've probably gone on less dates than i
have like
this is the slowest period in my life in
terms of dating me out there before this
[ __ ] before i was doing this youtube and
this stuff you know from ages like
28 to like 24 i was i i lived more in
the streets than i did in my own place
okay i should have been paying rent and
light bills out there i owe somebody
some money
because i was i was out there but now
that i'm so busy
and it's not even imagine the city said
that you're a light belt yeah yeah
you've been living in these streets
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's why i'm bored i was in these
streets
i was the streets [ __ ] come out come
see me i don't need a boombox i just got
tinder swiping outside the door
i'm going to be the one dressed like a
cone yo that's it
that's it a whole construction cone i'm
the streets that's right forget a
pothole i was a sinkhole man i was just
but oh man i you know when he spoke
about purpose like i really i really
believe in that when you are focused on
something and you really believe in it a
lot of
a lot of this other stuff starts to be
on the back burner the only way to apply
yourself and to really have
high level success from my experience
and from a lot of men who i've spoken to
it's like you gotta apply yourself you
can't afford to be the street you can't
afford to do that
right so that's a misconception that
people have sure when you get that first
you might be like
but generally my experience and from
talking to other dudes like they've
realized one it's not
rewarding and two it's not worth the
cost how much it affects your career
you start to think about man i could
have put my energy towards this towards
that
this really wasn't fulfilling other than
a quick ego trip it was kind of
refreshing to hear him say that because
you don't hear that kind of rare
talk in the men's field no absolutely
not yeah you cannot afford to be the
streets unless you're mike's kidder you
know what i mean
it was supposed to be so easy yeah
that's the formal uk people
even athletes you know people at high
levels if they try to engage in this too
much it affects their careers
generally you don't find too many
playboys who are able to make it really
far
get to or to meet their full potential
generally they make it in spite of
their need to consciously be everywhere
except
dennis rodman but even if he's the
exception so
you know he makes a rule even if you say
he's the exception it's like
sometimes you succeed despite the fact
that you put setbacks
for yourself but he could i mean some
dudes take shaq for example yeah
genetically gifted
unbelievable right yeah wasn't
disciplined when it came to his diet and
his workouts
it's no different than this you know
what i'm saying that's just something i
wanted to relate to you guys
it's and again this comes back to what i
said before it's like
the grass always seems greener and i've
seen a lot of my young homies go through
it
and they talk to me about like man i
want to be you know doing what you did
and all this stuff and i'm like
it's not it's not all that but go do you
if it serves you that's right because i
can't make you learn that lesson
sometimes sometimes you got to go
through it and they go through it and
they come out to the same conclusion
it's hard to be you know especially as
you get older and age like
i don't have time and he's right also
about the like
once you have a very good relationship
one where both people are caring towards
each other supportive and have each
other's backs and
it's not a you know a lot of images of
negative relations that you see a lot
you're like damn okay this is something
worth building upon so
and the worst part is you're sacrificing
for this but then you take away from
from meeting your potential which means
that you can't achieve the goals that
you want to do which is like potentially
support your family help the people
around you build for your community you
know it's like
if you ask me today what i derive
pleasure for it's like supporting those
around me that's what
makes me personally fulfilled right i'd
be sacrificing that to do all the other
stuff
does that seem right does that seem in
line with like the values that i want
so you have to ask what is what is your
purpose what it is that you want to
accomplish
right so that's just something that you
have to think about is there anything
else that you want to bring up no
no you know that no nothing to sell and
stuff no not really
no single life for you
you know it's like me and christianity
it's like me and christianity
right don't worry i'll zoom in on your
face
i'll zoom in on your face and be like
today i have a choice violence
yeah but it was not as violent as me
when i went in because whenever you said
that
whenever you wrote that i was like yeah
today you know why i wrote that
good why i wrote that because i knew
like a lot of people were gonna have a
visceral reaction to what you were
saying so i was just like
get a [ __ ] and it wasn't not it was not
even as bad as i thought it would be
no i thought people would be
you're good he's backing up he's backing
up i gotta let him know we still need
streets
okay we're still in these streets can
you hear the streets calling
you here i thought it would be worse and
it's funny i'm talking about this right
now because i
have like youtubers who i used to follow
way back in the day some of you guys
might know him hot damn iraq he actually
came out with a video recently
and he talks about the change in his
perspective as well and so it's
interesting to me that literally
everybody i know
who i've generally respected have kind
of realized that being out here in these
streets doing all this stuff
it's not worth it it's not worth it it's
generally not worth it and for the young
folks who are watching this young men
especially
i know what they might sell you i know
what the people around you might be
talking about
understand a lot of it's just fluff all
right a lot of it's just fluff focus on
yourself
focus on the things that you need to do
in the long run you'll definitely feel
more
fulfilled by that oh well you know
what's interesting
don't want to close the window at this
point the streets are calling let's let
them call for the rest of this video
but um it's kind of thematic for this
one specifically this one
this is very fitting this is very
fitting the street's calling
because the streets aren't coming they
be calling me these are called it excuse
me calling me it's funny because kevin
recently came out with
the whole topic of like high value men
don't cheat the exercise options
so how do you think you reconcile those
two things i don't know what he meant by
that
basically saying like high value men
like the dudes were at the top right if
you're married to them like
sometimes they just have a concubine
every now and then they have a side
check
it's something that's happened yeah i've
seen that abs i've seen it happen we've
seen it happen yeah
it's not something that is not out there
right
but do you think there's a bit of a
contradiction in regards to what he was
saying there in terms of the value of
that
and no i think those can actually
live together i don't think it was
necessarily contradicting myself i think
that it's possible that those
things can can coexist right
there's some high value man that's going
to look for whatever actually no let me
rephrase that
it's a possibility that those things are
actually
not even the same topic okay they're
it's not even the same people
i see what you're saying so when he's
talking about high value man it's gonna
sometimes have a concubine doesn't
necessarily mean that people are gonna
be in these sheets
it's not the same thing yeah i don't
think he's even talking about the same
thing right there and that's right
yeah it's possibility i don't think he
contradicts himself there he's all just
depicting two different things yeah
there's people out there high value or
no whatever the hell that means
that are just in these streets yeah
look i look at guys in the nfl and nba
who don't have the benefit of having to
work like we did per se they work in a
different environment
but where can you make yourself
competent and getting
these opportunities you realize where
you came from
and how rare it is you don't want to go
back
and taking the time to try to chase
women
is a disservice to you your purpose and
even the women because this will crumble
this will fall and and it's so sad to
see guys in the nfl after the nfl
the kids here kids there money falling
apart doing another now they're
on fix my life or whatever
um look
it's easy for me to say if you haven't
had enough success the first thing i do
is i go out and slay a bunch
trust me no sir no sir
um even with with the access i have
enough is enough you want what you want
and that's why my private life i keep it
very
very quiet i only deal with a certain
certain caliber woman
because it's already stressful enough
to be me you know how that goes in front
of the camera
and and and people are always looking
for something to
expose you about or this or that and
it's like you know what
i'm on my purpose i'm doing what i need
to do because i have an opportunity
that i don't want to waste no so many
guys
don't have this and this can be a
generational uh
blessing if i manage the opportunity
correctly so i think what he says there
is very reasonable and i kind of want to
play that because i think it's
a message that doesn't get put out there
enough and i think when people do put it
out there they put it out there like
being a player is shameful that's not
what i'm saying what i'm saying is as a
man it's generally your best
it's in your best interest to just
invest in yourself in that regards
because one
doing the other stuff is not nearly as
rewarding as people make it out to be
and two
you do yourself a disservice like you
said so that's just my advice to
to young men anything else no no
violence today
[Music]
okay